Queridos amigos, amigas, si buscáis en en
Google información sobre la gran ciudad de
San Luis, Missouri os toparéis con un montón
de artículos sobre su declive, sus problemas
sociales, los problemas raciales o la marginalidad.
Para que os hagáis una idea, a día de hoy,
cada año que pasa, San Luis pierde cerca
del 1% de su población.
[Vamos, que no hablamos, precisamente de la
ciudad más pujante de américa]
Esta ha sido la tendencia de los últimos
seis años, y nada indica que se vaya a revertir
en el corto plazo.
(Informe: St. Louis es la ciudad estadounidense
que más rápido se hunde - St. Louis Business
Journal)
Pero, un momento, porque San Luis no siempre
fue así.
Hablamos de la que un día fue la ciudad más
importante al oeste del Río Misisipi y una
de las más ricas, florecientes y con más
actividad económica de todos los Estados
Unidos. Un lugar muy próspero que además
era también uno de los hubs culturales y
artísticos del país.
Era una urbe mucho más grande y más importante
que alguna de las grandes metrópolis de Estados
Unidos actualmente. Con especial mención
a Chicago. Luego veréis por qué.
Esta es la otra cara, la cara más desconocida
de una ciudad, San Luis, que durante un tiempo
fue uno de los lugares más brillantes de
los Estados Unidos de América.
(San Luis fue fundada por los franceses en
1764, y luego, en el año 1803 adquirida por
el gobierno norteamericano como parte del
acuerdo de compra de Louisiana. Gracias a
su incorporación a la unión, a su privilegiada
ubicación junto al río Misisipi y a su papel
como puente entre los estados fundadores y
los sureños, ya en 1818 la ciudad se había
convertido en todo un centro de comunicaciones.
En gran medida gracias a los barcos mercantes
que desde aquí surcaban las aguas del Misisipi.
Tres años después, en 1821, Misuri adquirió
la categoría de Estado. En los años sucesivos
la ciudad experimentó una explosión de prosperidad
que multiplicó tanto su crecimiento económico
como demográfico.
Tanto es así que para 1860, tan sólo un
siglo después de su fundación, la ciudad
ya había superado los 150.000 habitantes,
y en los siguientes 10 años su población
se multiplicó de nuevo por dos, hasta superar
la cifra de los 300.000 habitantes. )
Y amigos, aunque estas cifras a ojos de hoy
pueden parecernos poca cosa, podéis creerme
cuando os digo que en esa época 300 mil habitantes
era el equivalente hoy a una ciudad de varios
millones de habitantes.
El caso, es que de esta forma San Luis llegó
a convertirse en uno de los grandes centros
estadounidenses de la industria de servicios
profesionales, como por ejemplo las finanzas
y la publicidad. Y de hecho, ocho empresas
de la lista Fortune 500 todavía están radicadas
allí.
Sin embargo, un momento, porque actualmente
las cosas son muy diferentes.
Por ejemplo, San Luis tiene la segunda mayor
tasa de delitos violentos de todo el país,
tan sólo por detrás de Detroit. En San Luis
1 de cada 51 personas fueron víctimas de
un delito violento tan solo durante el año
Y de hecho en 2020 fue también considerada
como una de las 10 ciudades más peligrosas
del todo el mundo según el Consejo Ciudadano
para la Seguridad Pública y la Justicia Penal,
una organización mexicana que cada año publica
un ranking con las ciudades más violentas
conforme al número de homicidios.
Pero, amigos, San Luis no sólo comparte con
Detroit - una ciudad de la que ya hablamos
en un vídeo que os dejo en la descripción
- las altas tasas de criminalidad, sino también
las de marginalidad y exclusión racial.
Pero, stop. No, este vídeo no lo vamos a
dedicar al San Luis de hoy. Con los datos
que hemos puesto sobre la mesa creo todos
nos podemos hacer una idea bastante clara
sobre cómo están las cosas. Por eso, lo
que queremos hacer en esta ocasión es hablaros
de algo un poquito diferente.
Algo para lo que tenemos que tenemos que remontarnos
unos cuantos años atrás en el tiempo.
Queridos amigos, en el siglo XIX dos ciudades
no demasiado lejanas competían mano a mano
por convertirse en el eje comercial más importante.
Una es, obviamente, San Luis, y la otra Chicago.
Sin embargo, mientras que Chicago es hoy una
próspera megaurbe, San Luis no es más que
una ciudad de tamaño medio, tirando a pequeño,
repleta de problemas y que sufre altísimas
tasas de abandono de edificios y mucha, muchísima
delincuencia.
Y la pregunta es, ¿Qué demonios pasó para
que San Luis cayera en desgracia y Chicago
se elevara a los cielos? ¿Qué marcó la
diferencia?
Pues bien, descubramoslo.
[Stop Un momento. Antes de continuar me gustaría
contaros una cosa.
La razón de ser de VisualPolitik es daros
a conocer los sucesos que explican las noticias,
lo que se esconde tras los grandes titulares
de la actualidad.
Y para poder seguir creciendo y mejorando
vosotros sois una parte fundamental. Por estar
semana tras semana justo ahí, al otro lado
de la pantalla, y también por la ayuda que
muchos de vosotros nos brindais en Patreon.
Un patreon que hemos puesto patas arriba para
darle vida y te permita convertirte en parte
del proyecto.
Por eso además de los contenidos exclusivos
para patronos que ya tenemos en marcha, como
por ejemplo nuestro boletín semanal o los
vídeos editoriales que tenemos en marcha,
lanzaremos también encuestas y consultas
periódicas en las que, por ejemplo, podréis
elegir temas para futuros vídeos o hacernos
llegar vuestras preguntas.
Además también hemos preparado productos
exclusivos que nunca pondremos a la venta.
Serán diseños exclusivos para Patreon.
Así que si quieres formar parte de VisualPolitik,
ya puedes hacerlo sumándote a nuestro Patreon.
Poco a poco irá cobrando más y más vida.
Os dejamos por aquí abajo el enlace a donde
encontraréis más información.
y dicho esto, continuemos.
(VÍCTIMA DE SÍ MISMA… Y DE LA MALA SUERTE)
Echad un vistazo atentamente a este gráfico.
A día de hoy San Luis tiene menos de 300.000
habitantes, en concreto unos 294.900. En el
año 1870 tenía 310.000.
Espera, ¿que en 1870 tenía más habitantes
que ahora? Pues sí, así es. No se trata
de ningún error.
De hecho, su población máxima se alcanzó
hace ya mucho tiempo, en la década de los
años 50, cuando la ciudad superó los 850
mil habitantes. Desde entonces San Luis ha
perdido casi el 70% de su población.
Y evidentemente esta no es la evolución natural
de una ciudad y ni mucho menos algo frecuente.
Es algo extraño, raro, sorprendente, insólito.
Pero para conocer las raíces de esta historia
tenemos que remontarnos hasta la década de
1850. En ese momento, San Luis y Chicago,
dos ciudades, relativamente cercanas, ambas
situadas en la cuenca del Misisipi y con acceso
fluvial directo a los asentamientos del medio
oeste, es cuando empezaron a competir ferozmente.
(En ese momento San Luis era una ciudad mucho
más grande y mucho más importante que Chicago,
que apenas tenía 30.000 habitantes en 1850.
En aquel entonces San Luis era el epicentro
del comercio norte-sur, un comercio que se
hacía fundamentalmente a través de barcos
de vapor a lo largo del río Misisipi.
Sí, hablamos de esos famosos barcos que salen
en las películas de época. Pues bien, debido
a su posición geográfica, San Luis era la
ciudad más norteña que estaba conectada
mediante una vía natural directa con Nueva
Orleans, los estados sureños y el Caribe.
Por su parte, la pequeña Chicago tenía en
ese momento a Nueva York como su principal
socio comercial y puerto de entrada y salida
al extranjero.)
Pero, amigos, podemos decir que San Luis ha
sido a lo largo de la historia una ciudad
acostumbrada a estar en el lugar correcto
pero no en el momento adecuado. O, quizas,
mejor dicho, nunca ha tenido un escenario
adecuado. Esta es una historia de cómo el
conformismo, la burocracia, la falta de dinamismo
y la poca ambición acabaron con una de las
grandes urbes del mundo occidental.
Pero, no nos desviemos. El caso es que en
1948 esta ciudad recibió su primer gran golpe.
Ese año se completó el canal que conectaba
los Grandes Lagos directamente con el río
Misisipi que, como ya sabéis, baña a San
Luis.
¿Y qué ciudad está situada en la orilla
de los Grandes Lagos, del lago Míchigan en
concreto? Exacto, Chicago.
Así que ya podéis imaginas que este hito
fue súmamente importante para la ciudad de
la judía y las pizzas de dos pisos: por primera
vez Chicago se sitúo en una posición privilegiada:
de repente la pequeña ciudad al borde de
los Grandes Lagos tenía acceso al comercio
fluvial con el sur de Estados Unidos.
Y no solo eso, desde allí se podía también
comerciar con la actual Canadá y además
estaba mejor conectada con la costa este,
sobre todo con Nueva York.
Así que, tal y como os podéis imaginar,
esto hizo que San Luis perdiera uno de sus
puntos más fuertes, ya que gracias a su enclave
en pleno Misisipi era hasta entonces un lugar
único para el comercio con los Estados del
sur, especialmente con la incipiente ciudad
de Nueva Orleans, donde desemboca el Misisipi.
Claro que la competencia nunca es un problema,
salvo que no quieras enfrentarla.
Me explico. Paralelamente al desarrollo del
canal, se empezaron a poner en marcha los
primeros proyectos de ferrocarriles en las
dos ciudades. Aunque eso sí, a una velocidad
muy diferente.
Y es que veréis, en esa época se consideraba
que el ferrocarril ayudaría a expandir el
área de influencia de las ciudades que se
habían desarrollado gracias a vías naturales
de transporte, cómo por ejemplo el Misisipi.
Digamos, que el ferrocarril permitía que
muchos condados pudieran acceder a las grandes
vías de transporte fluvial, empujando con
ello el crecimiento del estado y particularmente
de esas grandes ciudades, esos grandes polos
logísticos.
(Sin embargo, a pesar de ser una ciudad mucho
más grande y con muchos más recursos que
Chicago, San Luis, sus autoridades y sus grandes
empresarios vivian completamente volcados
al Misisipi. Esto es lo que explica en gran
medida la mayor lentitud a la hora de sacar
adelante los proyectos ferroviarios.
En cierta forma al tren se le veía con cierto
recelo, por competencia y porque tampoco se
percibía su importancia. La ciudad no lo
necesitaba. Así que mientras en Chicago estaban
apoyando, impulsando y construyendo nuevas
infraestructuras férreas, en San Luis los
planes aún continuaban ceñidos al papel.
Todo era más lento.)
Para colmo llegó el año 1861, el año en
el que explotó la Guerra Civil en los Estados
Unidos.
¿Recordáis que hace un momento comentamos
que buena parte del comercio de San Luis estaba
ligado a Nueva Orleans y a los estados del
sur?
Pues, el problema es que al estallar la guerra
civil, se cortaron los lazos comerciales con
esos estados secesionistas, dejando por tanto
a San Luis sin su mayor activo económico
y encima al alcanze del bando rival.
Así que en ese momento Chicago, que está
situada bastante más al norte, era considerada
como una plaza más segura, motivo por el
cual cobró mucho protagonismo durante los
cuatro años que duró la guerra, y también
en la postguerra.
(La guerra civil impulsó a Chicago respecto
a San Luis como la potencia industrial de
referencia, lo que también vino acompañado,
lógicamente, de más inversiones en infraestructuras.
Y sí, también de un enorme crecimiento demográfico.
Para 1890 Chicago ya tenía más del doble
de población que San Luis, y había superado
el millón de habitantes. Y eso a pesar de
que apenas 40 años antes no era más que
un pueblo grande de unos 30.000 habitantes.)
Amigos, San Luis perdió su posición. El
declive de su principal ruta comercial y el
desarrollo comparativamente menor del ferrocarril
hizo que poco a poco la ciudad se fuera quedando
atrás respecto a las grandes urbes norteamericanas.
Y aunque San Luis siguió creciendo con el
paso de los años, ya nunca volvió a brillar
como antes.
Porque recordad que estamos hablando de la
que era una de las ciudades más importantes
del país. Una ciudad que estaba prácticamente
al mismo nivel que Nueva York.
Ahora bien, cuándo vimos antes el gráfico
de la población lo que nos encontramos es
con un gran declive desde que en los años
50 alcanza su máximo nivel de población..
¿Qué demonios ha ocurrido desde entonces?
¿Qué provocó una caída de casi el 70%
en el número de habitantes? ¿Qué la ha
llevado a convertirse en una de las 10 ciudades
más peligrosas de todo el mundo.
Atentos.
(EL DETROIT 2.0)
Os lo decía al principio del vídeo: los
caminos de San Luis y de Detroit se han parecido
bastante.
Y es que, una vez perdida la batalla contra
Chicha, casi que podríamos decir, que el
siguiente rival fue Detroit. La entonces joya
de la industria del automóvil norteamericana
tenía competencia.
Ya a principios del siglo XX, San Luis y sus
alrededores se habían convertido en la segunda
región de Estados Unidos con mayor producción
de automóviles. Justo por detrás, evidentemente,
de Detroit.
De hecho, se dice que la primera gasolinera
de todo el país se puso en marcha aquí,
en San Luis. Y también se dice que fue en
este sitio dónde se produjo el primer accidente
de tráfico. Claro que yo no estoy muy seguro
de que parte de todo esto es verdad o leyenda.
El caso es que la industrialización hizo
que ambas ciudades tuvieran una enorme cantidad
de inmigración desde el sur de Estados Unidos,
especialmente población afroamericanos.
(La Gran Migración fue un fenómeno migratorio
masivo que movió a 6 millones de afro-americanos
desde los Estados del sur a los estados del
noreste, medio oeste y oeste del país.
Las difíciles condiciones económicas y la
dura segregación racial que se vivía en
el sur de Estados Unidos hizo que muchos afro-americanos
quisieran buscar un futuro mejor en las ciudades
industrializadas del norte. Entre esas ciudades,
estuvo, precisamente, San Luis.)
San Luis parecía recobrar su empuje, la ciudad
experimentó un boom inmobiliario y en 1904
albergó, incluso, la exposición universal
y los Juegos Olímpicos.
El problema es que la ciudad volvió a repetir
prácticamente los mismos errores de la segunda
mitad del siglo XIX: falta de diversificación
y parálisis progresiva. No había prácticamente
nada más que la industria del automóvil
y cuándo esta empezó a tener problemas todo
se vino abajo.
El proceso fue exactamente el mismo que os
contamos en el caso de Detroit: tenéis el
vídeo en la descripción. La crisis azotó
la ciudad, el paro se multiplicó, la delincuencia
se convirtió en algo habitual y muchas personas
de clase media comenzaron a escapar, a mudarse
a las afueras.
San Luis comenzó a estar dominada por edificios
abandonados, pozos de marginalidad, delincuencia
y muchos estupefacientes. El cocktail completo.
Es, precisamente, por esto que San Luis es
conocida como la Detroit 2.0.
El segundo Detroit del que muy poca gente
habla y que a día de hoy afronta problemas
casi tan graves como los de su vecina ciudad
norteña de Michigan. Un Detroit de marca
blanca que tiene un futuro tan complicado
como el original. Una ciudad que un día fue
una de las grandes estrellas de la potencia
norteamericana y que hoy lucha por salir adelante
convertida en una de las ciudades más peligrosas
de todo el mundo.
¿Podrá San Luis renacer y volver a ser un
lugar próspero repleto de sueños de personas
que buscan mejorar sus vidas? ¿Tendrá una
nueva ocasión esta ciudad de florecer y recuperar
la magia que un día tuvo?
Dejanos tu opinión por aquí abajo, en los
comentarios. Y ya sabes si te ha gustado este
vídeo dale like y suscríbete a nuestro canal
para no perderte nada de lo que está por
venir.
Una vez más, gracias por estar ahí. Un saludo
y hasta la próxima.